the Joe Rogan experience there's a real
concern among some people that we're
entering a phase of this country where
there's a real possibility of having
some sort of a civil unrest civil war
when you see something like these
Portland events when you see this kind
of chaos do you think that that's a
valid concern not for something that is
across the country but perhaps very
regional or to the city itself and not
so much like civil war but the violence
that is done and planned by an tyfa is
meant to make the wider public not just
polarizing hate each other but also
began to distrust the institutions that
are in place that i meant to uphold
democracy so the police in portland have
come under fire for example not just
from the radical left but a lot of
people who are normally very Pro police
are finding like what is wrong it's
important police like we can't even
trust them so there's if things just
continue I think the violence will
continue to escalate leading to a death
or death that's my real concern it's my
real concern as well and you think this
is particularly unique to Portland in
the way they're treating and addressing
it I'm trying to think of comparable
other cities that have had some of these
issues so for example in San Jose in
2016 Trump supporters when they were
leaving a Trump rally were brutally
assaulted by mobs of people and then
there was a lawsuit that was launched
against the city for basically putting
citizens in the way a danger the way
they were funneled outside of this event
led them directly in front of these
violent protesters who attacked them you
know and those footage that went viral
that year since then policing tactics
have changed in San Jose as far as I
know
and you know involve the lawsuit so like
sometimes it takes lawsuits for the
local government to start protecting
people's civil rights so right now as
bad as it is it does seem confined to
Portland we haven't seen that for
example in Berkeley the type of violence
as in 2017 when my logo came like you
know that hasn't been repeated for a
year and a half now so but it takes the
political will of those in power to
enforce the law right
so you mentioned lawsuits what lawsuits
are you pursuing well immediately right
now what I would like to see is the city
of Portland carry out a full
investigation and hold accountable all
those who were involved in attacking me
or aided in that as well
and then as the evidence whether
evidence leaves if this shows that there
were was dereliction of duty from those
in power then you know I reserve my
judgment my lawyer reserves judgment for
you know who if anyone gets sued at that
point but right now I'm very focused on
seeing that in putting pressure on the
city to arrest people who are
responsible and charged on and get
convictions as well
all right in in closing because I know
you gotta get out here is there a silver
lining to any this I mean do you think
that perhaps your assault and the the
fact that the police did intervene is
actually allowing people understand the
the real significance of this the the
real problem of this that it's this is a
real issue a gigantic one in fact that
goes against the core tenants the value
of a free expression and and the ability
to gather and communicate safely in
public yeah as hard as it was for me to
see silver lining when I was laying in
hospital with so much pain and there's
one and that is that everybody paid
attention to what happened to me it was
a big story even the mains
dream liberal press cannot ignore it and
I'm hoping that from that it goes beyond
just being a headline but forcing the
national discourse to change on how it
views and talks about mt4 we'll see if
that happens I feel encouraged that
we're beginning to see some cracks in
the way that anti-fur has been protected
by sympathetic writers in journalists
and those in mainstream media I mean the
fact that keith Ellison deleted that
photo that he shared a year ago right
after that was attacked I think
indicates that there's even he faces a
certain pressure that it may not be good
for a mainstream politician to so
actively promote this movement and I
hope it continues to move in that
direction if you had a crystal ball and
you were looking at the future what do
you what do you think you would say well
based on the press release press
conference at the mayor did two days ago
him not sure not having any proposals it
seems like more violence has to happen
[Applause]